To find the numbers here, we list the factor pairs of 24. 1 and 24 is a factor
pair, since they multiply to give us 24. After 1, I should try 2. Well, 24 is
even, so 2 definitely goes into it. 2 times 12 is 24. 3 goes into 24 as well, so
3 times 8 is another factor pair. 4 and 6 is another factor pair. I know that 5
doesn't go into 24, because, since this number doesn't end in a 0 or a 5. And
then, if i try 6, I repeat a factor pair, so really, I'm done here. Any higher
factor pairs will be repeated like 8 and 3, 12 and 2, and 24 and 1, so I look at
my list of factor pairs and I see which pair adds to 10. Well, 4 and 6 add to
10, so that must be the answer. Here are the factor pairs for 36. And notice
that I've only listed the positive factors here. We could also have negative 1
and negative 36, but we'll talk about that later. I just want to find the pair
that adds to 13. 4 and 9 add to 13, so that must be my answers for my number
puzzle. Great work if you got those two right.